Hey, you guys, now is, like, the perfect time for me to do some vocal warm-ups because nobody's around. So, hangy, pingy, pingy, pingy, popcorn, peanuts, get them if you want them. Hey, I got some Twizzlers over here, and I got a little payday if you want a payday. Hey, hey, hey, woo, who. Welcome to SmartL. Smart less. You may tell you something. This is why we don't have a video component on this show.
嘿，各位，现在简直是——是——我做开嗓练习的绝佳时机，因为周围没人。所以，弹呀，叮呀，叮呀，叮呀，爆米花，花生，想要就来拿。嘿，我这有些Twizzlers软糖，如果你想要的话，我还有点零花钱。嘿，嘿，嘿，呜，呼。欢迎来到SmartL。Smart less。我跟你说个事。这就是为什么我们这个节目不设视频组件的原因。
What's going on today on top of my head? Don't you dare. It looks, you look gorgeous. See, I'd have to. You look. You know who you look like? You look like the star of that very successful new streaming show called Black Rabbit that we all love.
今天我脑子里在想些什么呢？你敢。它看起来，你看起来美极了。看，我不得不。你看。你知道你长得像谁吗？你长得像那部非常成功的新流媒体剧《黑兔》的主演，我们大家都喜欢的那部。
That show's amazing. You look like the star of Black Rabbit. Black Rabbit streaming now on Netflix. Wait, when it's not out yet, is it? Well, no. By the time this airs. What's the date, Jamie? Wait, what does it come out, Jay?
那部剧太棒了。你看起来就像《黑兔》的主演。《黑兔》正在Netflix上热播。等等，现在还没上映吧，是吗？呃，没有。等这个播出的时候。杰米，今天是几号？等等，杰伊，它什么时候上映？
September 18th. Wait, Jason, that's really exciting. Oh, my God, the show is going to be so good. It's going to be what so. We don't need to talk about that. We don't need to talk about it. It's exciting. I do think it's enough with the London thing and the Long Island thing.
9月18日。等等，杰森，这真的很令人兴奋。天哪，这部剧一定会非常棒。它将成为——所以。我们不需要谈这个。我们不需要谈它。这很令人兴奋。我确实觉得伦敦的事和长岛的事够多的了。
Los Angeles and me, my heart, my mind, my eyes, my ears, my chest, my chest misses the feeling of your chest against it. I know. Please come home. Were you at dinner last night? I was going to FaceTime. Did you go to our message? No, there was no Sunday, Sunday. I was going to FaceTime you out of the blue because I know who you love it out of it.
洛杉矶和我，我的心、我的思想、我的眼睛、我的耳朵、我的胸口、我的胸口想念你的胸口贴着它的感觉。我知道。请回家吧。你昨晚去吃晚饭了吗？我本来打算打FaceTime的。你去看我们的消息了吗？不，没有周日周日。我本来想突然给你打FaceTime的，因为我知道你多喜欢……
When's the last time there was a Sunday Sunday Sunday? two weeks ago maybe three weeks ago I do miss that a lot hot fudge fun day well I'll say it one more time still rolling the hot fudge fun day hot fudge fun oh you did say it right because you would have a hot fudge there
上一次有“周日周日周日”是什么时候？两周前，也许三周前。我真的很怀念那个热腾腾的奇趣圣代。好吧，我再说一遍，那个热腾腾的奇趣圣代还在。热腾腾的奇趣圣代，热腾腾的——哦，你确实说对了，因为你会在那里吃个热乎的。
yeah oh you brought it together hey thanks but you brought your own fudge isn't that correct oh yeah well you're on the corner that's where it's made I mean that's a Sean Hayes move
对，哦，你们凑到一块儿去了。嘿，谢谢，不过你带了自己的糖浆，对吧？哦，对，你在那个角落，那是它制作的地方。我的意思是，那是肖恩·海耶斯的作风。
remember I brought my own fudge to my birthday party you did bless your heart you were out of town no I brought You brought your own toppings. I brought my own caramel to my birthday party because we went to this place and they were like, oh, they don't have the full arsenal
还记得我把自己的糖浆带到我的生日派对上吗？你确实带了，老天保佑你。你当时不在城里。不，我带了——你带了自己的配料。我把自己的焦糖带到了我的生日派对上，因为我们去了这个地方，然后他们说，哦，他们没有全套的……
of Sunday toppings on Sunday nights, whatever. That was nice, though. So luckily, our friend Sean organized it very sweetly. J.B., you were in Atlanta. And no, and then I show up with, I had it in my pocket, and I did it a little bit for effect because I knew I was going to get shit for it. I pull it out.
周日晚上的圣代配料，诸如此类。不过那挺好的。所以幸运的是，我们的朋友肖恩非常贴心地组织了它。杰·B，你在亚特兰大。然后不，接着我出现了，我把它放在口袋里，我这么做有点是为了效果，因为我知道我会因此挨骂。我把它拿出来。
Sean, actually, you didn't really give me shit. You kind of laughed. Camel gave me a lot of shit, and then sure is shit. When the ice cream came out, everybody said, hey, can you pass it down here? And Kimmel was first. Was it caramel sauce? Yeah, it was caramel sauce.
肖恩，其实你没怎么骂我。你有点笑了。卡梅尔骂了我一通，果不其然。冰激凌端上来的时候，每个人都说，嘿，能把它传到这边来吗？基梅尔是第一个。那是焦糖酱吗？对，那是焦糖酱。
And I was like, oh, do you want some now? Camel. You know. Wait, Sean, how do you say that word? Carmel. I say caramel ice cream or caramel swirl, right? I mean, I kind of toggle between the two. How is it spelt?
然后我就像，哦，你现在想要点吗？卡梅尔。你知道的。等等，肖恩，你那个词怎么发音？卡梅尔。我说的是焦糖（caramel）冰激凌还是焦糖漩涡，对吧？我的意思是，我在这两之间来回切换。它是怎么拼的？
How many A's are? Spelt. Spell. Spell. C-A-R-A-M-E-L. There's two A-M-E-L. Spelt. I said spelled. I said spelled. You said spelt. I didn't. I meant, I, it came out as that. I meant spelled.
有多少个A？拼的。拼。拼。C-A-R-A-M-E-L。有两个A-M-E-L。拼的。我说的是拼的。我说的是拼的。你说了 spelt。我没有。我的意思是，我，它说出来就是那样。我指的是 spelled。
I know, Sean. I know this guy. Please. Wait, spelt is a kind of... From the guy who says Carmel. Are you fucking joking? He's still, I still can't believe he was shocked that Beatles. What are you saying that is you're getting thrown out of a moving car? What Carmel!
我知道，肖恩。我了解这家伙。拜托。等等，spelt是一种……这话出自一个说“卡梅尔”的人之口。你他妈在开玩笑吧？他还在——我还是不敢相信他竟然对披头士乐队感到震惊。你刚才说的那话是会被人从行驶中的车里扔出去的吗？什么卡梅尔！
Wait, I have a crazy story. I'd love a new dad joke, too. I've worn out my haze can. I can do lots of dad jokes ready. Okay, hurry up, because our guest is probably falling asleep. All right, you want a long story or a short dad joke? Short dad joke. Yeah.
等等，我有一个疯狂的故事。我也想要个新的冷笑话。我的海耶斯笑话库存都用光了。我会讲很多冷笑话，准备好了吗。好吧，快点，因为我们的客人都快睡着了。好吧，你想听一个长故事还是一个短冷笑话？短冷笑话。好吧。
Amal and Juan are identical twins, and their mom only carries one photo in her wallet, because if you've seen Juan, you've seen them all boy that's a long way to go for shit I laughed out loud when I heard that all right all right we're going to get to our guests
阿迈勒和胡安是同卵双胞胎，他们的妈妈钱包里只放了一张照片，因为如果你见过胡安，你就见过他们所有人。天哪，为了一个烂笑话铺垫这么久。我听到的时候放声大笑了。好吧，好吧，我们要请出我们的嘉宾了。
but real first I just want to say you know saw Will's film second time the other day I'm still I can't wait to see it little fucking starstruck when I'm looking at this guy now he's kind of ruined things it's kind of like when I saw you doing your Tony award-winning play that you're now doing in London.
但首先，我只是想说，你知道，前几天看了威尔的电影第二遍。我还是——我迫不及待想看它了。当我看着这家伙的时候，我有点被大明星给镇住了。他现在有点把事情搞砸了。这有点像我看到你演那个托尼奖获奖话剧的时候，你现在正在伦敦演的那个。
It's, you guys, you guys, you've got real talent. You know, you really dumb it down on this show, but you both have a little something special in there. Yeah. You can keep hitting. Ouch, boy, that compliment hurts. Yeah. Well, yeah, I'd like to balance it out.
这是，你们这些家伙，你们有真正的天赋。你知道，你们在这个节目里把格调拉得很低，但你们俩内心深处都有点特别的东西。对。你可以继续挖苦。哎哟，天哪，这夸奖真刺耳。好吧，好吧，我想平衡一下。
But fuck me, Arnett. Listen, listen, her, it's called, is this thing on, triple dot? Some people say ellipses. But it's a great film. It's coming your way. I think towards the end of the year. Wait, so Black Rabbit comes out in September.
但操我的，阿奈特。听着，听着，她，它叫，是这个在播放吗，三个点？有些人叫省略号。但这是一部很棒的电影。它就要上映了。我想在年底左右。等等，所以《黑兔》9月上映。
Is this thing on comes out in November? December. December. This is like a big deal. But if you're at the New York Film Festival, you can see it there in October. That's true. That's true.
《是这个在播放吗》11月上映？12月。12月。这就像是一件大事。但如果你去纽约电影节，你可以在10月份在那里看到它。没错。那是真的。
Well, thank you. It's fantastic. And if you're in London right now, still, even now, if you're in London, you can go to see. At the Delicourt. At the Delacourt Theater. You can go. How about Oscar?
嗯，谢谢。太棒了。如果你现在在伦敦，甚至现在，如果你在伦敦，你可以去看。在德拉克法院。在德拉克法院剧院。你可以去。奥斯卡怎么样？
At the Chimmy Chirry sauce. Chimmy Chiri at the Chimitri stage at the Delicourt? Barbican. What about Oscar? What about that Oscar? What about Oscar?
在奇米奇里酱。奇米奇里在德拉克法院的奇米奇里舞台？巴比肯。奥斯卡呢？那个奥斯卡怎么样？奥斯卡怎么了？
What about Oscar? Oh, God, here we go, we go. It's called, what is it called? Leave it to Oscar? Here comes Oscar. Hey, what do you know about Oscar? Leave it to Oscar. All right, listen to me.
奥斯卡怎么了？哦，天哪，开始了，开始了。它叫，它叫什么？交给奥斯卡？奥斯卡来了。嘿，你对奥斯卡了解多少？交给奥斯卡。好吧，听我说。
Guys, guys, quick reminder before the guests, I just want to say, tickets go on sale. Friday, September 12th for our Hollywood Bowl night that we're doing. We're very excited about that. Very, very excited. Saturday, November 15th, right? Is our show date? Saturday, November 15th, yeah.
伙计们，伙计们，在嘉宾到来之前快速提醒一下，我只想说，我们即将举办的露天剧场之夜门票将于9月12日星期五开始发售。我们对此感到非常兴奋。非常，非常兴奋。11月15日星期星期六，对吧？是我们的演出日期？11月15日星期六，是的。
It's going to be incredible. Come enjoy the chat and giggle under the stars in a very refined setting there in the hills of Los Angeles. There won't be any fireworks, but except on stage, huh, guys? There's going to be a lot of fireworks. All right, let's get into the show, please. Yeah. For your listening pleasure today,
这将是难以置信的。快来洛杉矶群山之中那个非常精致的环境里，在星空下享受聊天和傻笑吧。不会有任何烟花，但除了舞台上，对吧，伙计们？会有很多烟花的。好吧，让我们进入正题吧，请。 yeah。为了你们今天的聆听乐趣，
we have for you a woman with a real handle on how to make you laugh. But she's not a joke teller. She's an actor of the highest level. Her ability to play characters that are so odd and eccentric. Love characters. It's something you end up watching
我们请来了一位真正懂得如何让你发笑的女士。但她不是一个讲笑话的人。她是一位最高级别的演员。她扮演那些古怪又离奇的角色的能力。热爱角色。你最终会带着
with amazement and shock as you dab the laugh tears from your eyes. It's why she's been nominated for every single year she was on Saturday Night Live. I think I've got that right. I could not be a bigger fan of her talent and for just being around her.
惊奇和震惊观看，同时擦去眼角的笑泪。这就是为什么在她效力《周六夜现场》的每一年里，她都获得提名。我想我没记错吧。对于她的才华，以及仅仅能和她呆在一起，我都无法表达我有多崇拜她。
Very cool of her to come hang out with us today. He's welcome, one of the greats, Miss Kate, the great McKinnon. Yes. Willie got it. She was still awake. There's an... Oh, wait, she's in the Criterion closet.
她能来和我们一起闲逛，真是太酷了。欢迎她，一位伟大的艺术家，凯特女士，伟大的麦金农。是的。威利说对了。她还醒着。有个……哦，等一下，她在标准收藏（Criterion）的壁橱里。
Uh-oh, she's got the Criterion Collection behind her. Are those DVDs behind you or just a bunch of one-acts? No, no, there are books. I'm in a... Hi. Hi. Oh, hello. Oh, hello.
噢不，她身后有标准收藏（Criterion Collection）！你身后那些是DVD还是一堆独幕剧？不，不，那是书。我在一个……嗨。嗨。哦，你好。哦，你好。
No, I'm in the offices of the... publisher of the book that I'm here to promote. Okay, let's start right off with it. But we don't have to talk about that right away, but we should at some point. Let's pretend like we're not. Let's let it come up organically. The name of the new book is purple, purple pearl. It's about a deep sea diver.
不，我在我这次来宣传的这本书的出版商的办公室里。好吧，我们马上切入正题吧。但我们不用马上谈那个，不过我们应该在某个时候谈谈。让我们假装我们没有在谈。让我们让它自然而然地出现。新书的名字叫《紫色，紫色明珠》（purple, purple pearl）。它是关于一个深海潜水员的。
Take it from there. Jason, that's her volume. Oh, she's putting her glasses on. That means she wrote a book. These are fake glasses that I wear to feel more comfortable. That's incredible. They provide a barrier between me and my interlocutoris that I need in order to feel safe. I can see you, but you can't come close to me.
从那开始吧。杰森，那是她的音量。哦，她把眼镜戴上了。那意味着她写了一本书。这些是我戴着为了感觉更舒服的假眼镜。这太不可思议了。它们在我与对话者之间提供了一道我为了感到安全所需要的屏障。我能看见你，但你不能靠近我。
Wait, are you reading from the book right now? Is this the first chapter of the book? Wow. I have never been on a podcast before. No, truly? Are you serious? Is this your first podcast? I've never been, yes.
等等，你现在是在照着书读吗？这是书的第一章吗？哇。我以前从来没上过播客。真的吗？你认真的？这是你的第一个播客吗？我从来没有，是的。
No way. And I'm afraid. No, what do you don't be? We're super safe. It's like we're just ringing out. And no one can see you. They can just hear you. No one, yeah.
真的假的？我很害怕。不，你为什么要害怕呢？我们这超级安全。就像我们只是在打电话。而且没人能看见你。他们只能听见你。没人，是的。
Even though you look incredible. Even though I have these glasses on to protect. Are you literally in a closet? Is that why you're whispering? No, no. I speak in dulcet tones. This is my real voice. And the presence of the microphone in my mouth is also making it easier for me to speak in my most dulcet tones.
尽管你看起来棒极了。尽管我戴着这些眼镜来保护自己。你真的在一个壁橱里吗？这就是你为什么在说悄悄话的原因吗？不，不。我用轻柔的语调说话。这是我的真实声音。麦克风贴在我嘴边的存在也让我更容易用我最轻柔的语调说话。
You just have a deep, deep, deep in the throat. You know what's really powerful, Kate, is when you can bring it down and you can bring it down, and you can bring, you control the tone and the volume like that, that's real power. They lean in. They lean in. They pulled over. Or they pulled the car over.
你的声音深沉，深沉，深沉在喉咙里。凯特，真正厉害的是，当你能把它压低，再压低，然后你可以把——你这样控制语调和音量，这才是真正的力量。他们会倾听。他们会倾听。他们把车靠边停了。或者他们把车靠边停了。
Or they leave. No. They could leave. But if they can't see you in the glasses, at least they can hear you now. Hey, listen, purple pearl. Smooth a barretta. Is about somebody who dives for pearls. They're only purple if they're super deep.
或者他们离开。不。他们可以离开。但如果他们透过眼镜看不到你，至少他们现在能听见你。嘿，听着，《紫色、紫色明珠》。苏珊·巴雷塔。是关于一个潜水采珍珠的人。只有在极深的地方它们才是紫色的。
So this is a diver that is particularly, talented at diving deep? I think I've got it right. It's a diver named Natalie. And she has lost her costume jewelry and she gets in trouble because it's her mother's costume jewelry. What a kid. Is this really it?
所以这是一个特别擅长深潜的潜水员？我想我理解对了。这是一个名叫娜塔莉的潜水员。她弄丢了她的戏服珠宝，然后她遇到了麻烦，因为那是她母亲的戏服珠宝。真是个孩子。真的是这样吗？
And no, it's not. But I think I've just plotted my new series so I am going to go because I'm inspired. By the way, if you open a show with somebody losing costume, jewelry, I'm always. Me too.
不，不是的。但我想我刚刚构思好了我的新剧，所以我得走了，因为我受到了启发。顺便说一句，如果一个剧以某人弄丢戏服珠宝开场，我总是会。我也是。
It's a detective show. Have you ever lost something that you really weren't supposed to lose? My phone? My dad? That's the worst. That is about the worst feeling. You know what you lost a few years ago, Jason,
这是一部侦探剧。你有没有弄丢过什么你真的不该弄丢的东西？我的手机？我爸爸？那是糟糕透顶的。那绝对是最糟糕的感觉。你知道你几年前弄丢了什么吗，杰森，
but you found? Dignity? Yep. Yeah. Yeah. And I just hit my head on the wall behind me. I don't know. Hey, listen, I want to get right to...
但你找到了？尊严？没错。是的。是的。而且我刚撞到我身后的墙上。我不知道。嘿，听着，我想直接进入……
Pete McKinnon. Can I just say, I think that you're, I think you're so funny. Oh gosh, you know, we don't have to do this. No, you're so great. No, this is part of the podcast. You have to put up with this on the podcast. Yeah, yeah. So you have to sit here and take it.
皮特·麦金农。我能说吗，我觉得你，我觉得你太有趣了。哦天哪，我们不必这么做。不，你太棒了。不，这是播客的一部分。在播客里你必须忍受这个。对，对。所以你必须坐在这里全盘接受。
You're so funny and you're so, um, original and cool. I just, I don't know you at all. Really? No. And I've never met her. We've, Kate, we've never. I feel like we have, you know, a lifelong fan. John, you met our guest?
你太有趣了，而且你太，嗯，独一无二又很酷。我只是，我根本不认识你。真的吗？不。而且我从未见过她。我们，凯特，我们从未。我觉得我们一直是，你知道的，一生的粉丝。约翰，你见过我们的嘉宾？
and passing we've said hello yes but never like spent time on the road yes yes we were I was driving at a red light yeah it's at a red light you drive an 88 Volvo station wagon right that's me but Kate I remember the first time I was doing a the My Rudolph show it was like it was going to be a thing that was only one episode undelated and and it was your first year I think of Saturday Night Live. And Lauren was at the shoot that I was doing with Maya. And I turned to Lauren. Lauren Michael.
擦肩而过，我们打过招呼，是的，但从没有像那样一起在路上呆过。是的，是的，我们当时——我当时在红灯前开车，是的，在红灯前。你开一辆88年的沃尔沃旅行车，对吧？那是我。但凯特，我记得我第一次做玛娅·鲁道夫的节目时，那就像是一件只会播出一集的临时事务，而且那是你在《周六夜现场》的第一年。洛恩在我跟玛娅一起拍摄的片场。我转头对洛恩说。洛恩·迈尔斯。
And I said, hey, that new girl, Kate McKinnon. And he said, he goes, isn't she special? I go, she is such a superstar. And he's like, I know we all know. We all feel it. And I was just like, so everybody knew it right when you came on. Lauren said that. My son said that, yeah.
我说，嘿，那个新来的女孩，凯特·麦金农。他说，他说，她不是很特别吗？我说，她简直是个超级巨星。他说，我知道，我们都知道。我们都有这种感觉。我当时就想，所以你一上节目大家就都知道了。洛恩这么说的。我儿子也这么说，是的。
That's beautiful. Thank you for saying that. But now, Kate, when was it, when was it? the first time you heard that um like how old were you when you privately because you're a very humble person you didn't like go out and say hey uh everybody thinks i'm great you just internally you thought hey you know what i think i can make people laugh and i like the feeling and i want to do a little bit more of it how old were you were you like this ismr episode were you like 20 um when did it start happening for you oh my god this is the most intimate smartness ever um is it okay well i know i um gosh
这太美妙了。谢谢你这么说。但现在，凯特，那是什么时候，那是什么时候？你第一次听到那个——比如你私底下多大年龄时——因为你是一个非常谦逊的人，你不会跑出去说“嘿，大家都觉得我很棒”——你只是在心里想，“嘿，你知道吗，我觉得我能让人发笑，我喜欢这种感觉，我想再多做一点”。你当时多大？你是像这个ismr剧集一样吗？你当时20岁左右？——嗯，这从什么时候开始发生的？哦，天哪，这是《SmartLess》有史以来最亲密的一集——呃，没关系，好吧，我知道，我——天哪，你知道吗，好吧，我在一个克里斯——我在教堂的一个选美比赛里，一个戏剧，真的。我是什么教派的？循道宗（Methodist）？好吧，嗯——但像是北方的循道宗——所以每个人都像——灰扑扑的，有点荷兰血统，皮肤粉白。我们在排演一部话剧，《但以关和狮子坑》（Daniel and the Lion's Den）。我当时演的好像是波斯王居鲁士。这个我不太熟。
you know what it was okay i was in a chris i was in a pageant at church a play really i was what denomination methodist okay um but like northern methodists so like everyone is like just gray and of like Dutch descent and has, you know, chalky skin. And we were doing a play, Daniel and the Lion's Den. And I believe I was playing Cyrus King of Persia. This one I don't know so well.
所以你演的是居鲁士，这是个好角色。我忘了，是的，不，这真的是个好角色。我决定用英国口音来演它。为了让自己感觉更舒服。而那些循道宗教徒，他们对这个很感兴趣。他们觉得这是一个极其搞笑的选择，对吧？他们没有被冒犯吗？因为他是波斯王。
So you're playing Cyrus, that's the choice part. I forget that, yeah, no, it's a really good part. And I decided to do it in a British accent. to make myself feel more comfortable. And those Methodists, they got a kick out of that. They thought it was a hilarious choice, yes? They weren't offended? Because he's the king of Persian.
为什么会用英国……不，不，我当时在用英国口音，他们在笑，我只是总是喜欢模仿除我自己的声音之外的其他声音，因为我自己的声音，你知道，你一直在听。就像是，它就会这样。这是一个选择。这是一个选择。这是一种接触外界的方式。
Why would have a British? No, no, I was doing a British accent, and they were laughing, and I just always liked to do different voices other than my own, because my own, you know, you're hearing it. It's like, it does it. It was a choice. It was a choice. It was a way to reach out.
我想说的是，你的疯狂之中自有循道宗的逻辑。但你当时觉得这会很好笑吗？还是你这么做是为了保护自己，然后大家的笑声有点出乎意料？或者你是在尝试？就是你刚才说的那样。真的吗？所以这是一个惊喜。你当时想，哦，如果我把事情稍微扭曲一点，A，这能保护我。
What I'm saying is there was a Methodist to your madness. But did you think it was going to be funny? Or were you doing it to like kind of protect yourself and then the laughter was a bit of a surprise? Or were you trying? That what you just said. Really? So it was a surprise. You were like, oh, if I kind of bend things a bit, A, it protects me.
B，我能收获笑声，这会是不错的社交资本。是的，完全正确。是的。我们当时多大？我想说10岁。10岁。但一直以来，你知道的，在我的家庭里长大，每个人都在模仿声音。
And B, I get laughter and that could be nice social capital. Yes, exactly. Yes. And how old were we? I want to say 10. 10. But there were always, you know, growing up in my family, everyone was doing voices.
你必须模仿声音，否则你就会被踢出去。不，那不是真的。这个家庭。这是在餐桌周围。被踢下去。是的。不，我没有兄弟。这是在哪？
You had to do voices, or you got kicked out. No, that's not true. The family. This is around the dinner table. Kick down. Yeah. No, I didn't have a brother. Where is this?
在餐桌周围，你知道的，醒来，去睡觉，只有声音，声音，长岛。大家都是有趣的人。长岛的哪个部分？你知道的，北海岸（North Shore）。北海岸。比如，我们说的是牡蛎湾（Oyster Bay）。
Around the dinner table, you know, waking up, going to bed, just voices, voices, Long Island. People were funny people. What part of Long Island? You know, the North Shore. The North Shore. Like, we're talking about Oyster Bay.
萨福克，我们说的是萨福克，我们说的是萨福克，拿骚，拿骚，对吧？是的，人们都被洗脑了。不，拿骚。非常好。你呢？哦，他一路都在。我们在说像道格拉斯顿（Douglaston）那样的吗？
Suffolk, we're talking to Suffolk, we're talking to Suffolk, NASA, NASA, right? Yeah, people are washed. No, NASA. Very good. What about you? Oh, he's all the way. Are we talking like Douglaston?
我们在说什么？不，不太算道格拉斯顿。好吧。你看过那个关于杀害了所有这些人的家伙的纪录片吗？嘿，凯特，等一下。好吧，我们走，肖恩。吉尔戈海滩（Gilgo Beach）指南？是的，是的。
What are we talking about? No, not quite Douglaston. Okay. Did you see that documentary about that guy who killed all those people? Hey, Kate, hold on one second. Yeah, we'll go, Sean. The Gilgo Beach Guide? Yes, yes.
我刚看了。哦，他。太疯狂了。肖恩对真实犯罪纪录片系列的快速热评。这太难以置信了。是吗？你为什么不提那个大规模杀人犯？
I just watched it. Oh, him. It was crazy. Quick hot take from Sean on the documentary True Crime series. It was unbelievable. Was it? Why didn't you mention the mass murderer?
还有20、20年以来的其他事吗？你想跟观众聊聊吗？《芭比》怎么样？你看过那个吗？嘿，那个泰德·邦迪。那《芭比》呢？那个奇怪的芭比怎么样？天哪，太喜欢了。
Anything else from 20, 22? You want to get the audience to? How about Barbie? Have you seen that? Hey, that Ted Bundy. How about Barbie? What about that weird Barbie? God, loved it.
是的，顺便说一句，凯特演了《芭比》。等等，什么？她演了怪咖芭比？蠢货。言归正传，凯特。我们成长过程中，你知道，我们的巨型事件。不，不，对不起，天哪，成长过程中的巨型事件。我是说，麦克风就在我的嘴边。
Yeah, by the way, Kate was in Barbie. Wait, what? Did she play weird Barbie? Stupid ass. Back to you, Kate. We growing up, you know, our big thing. No, no, I'm sorry, gosh, the big thing growing up. I mean, the microphones, my mouth is right there.
你不需要投射声音。我在舔麦克风。我觉得我不需要投影。成长过程中的巨型事件是艾米·菲舍尔（Amy Fisher）、乔伊·巴塔福科（Joey Buttafuoco）事件。那是个好案子。乔伊·巴塔福科是我祖父的汽车修理工。真的假的？
You don't need to throw. I'm licking the microphone. I feel like I don't need to project. The big thing growing up was the Amy Fisher, Joey Buttafuoco. Incident. That was a good one. Joey Buttafuco was my grandfather's auto mechanic. No way.
而且这让人兴奋，因为它是我们的。这是地地道道长岛的。而且，你知道，我不知道。你祖父被盘问过吗？他被盘问过吗？你祖父被盘问过吗？我想没有。他会说的，但我们，这只是，你知道的……
And it was exciting because it was ours. It was Long Island, it was Long Island to a T. And, you know, I didn't know. Was your grandfather deposed? Was he deposed? Was your grandfather deposed? I suppose not. He would have said, but we, it was just, you know,
我和我的朋友们，我们会玩那个。我们会重现这个传奇。哦，真的吗？你们会？而我当时并没有意识到艾米·菲舍尔当时正在被贩卖。艾米·菲舍尔被贩卖了？哦，是的。不，你不知道吗？不，当然不知道。我也不知道。
and my friends and I, we would play that. We would enact the saga. Oh, really? You would? And I didn't realize at the time that Amy Fisher was being trafficked. Amy Fisher was being trafficked? Oh, yeah. No, you didn't know that? No, of course not. I didn't know that either.
她当时17岁。他35岁。这，你知道的。是的，她被贩卖了。从萨福克到拿骚。好吧，那里有很多交通。是的，特别是当你开到大内克（Great Neck）的时候。如果你在北方公园大道（Northern Parkway）上，那就别提了。威尔，你对那儿门清啊。是的，我懂。
She was 17. He was 35. It was, you know. Yeah, she was being trafficked. From Suffolk to NASA. Well, there's a ton of traffic. Yeah, especially as you get into Great Neck. If you're on the Northern Parkway, forget it. Will, you know your stuff. Yeah, I do.
你一定上过米多布鲁克（Meadowbrook），老弟。这是什么？我当然上过米多布鲁克。你是那里人吗？这算什么？我女儿现在就在长岛。没错。哇。
You've been on the Meadowbrook, man. What is this? Of course I've been on the Meadowbrook. You're from there? What is this? I'm on Long Island right now. Yep. Wow.
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。所以你演了那个话剧，然后呢？你开始演小品喜剧了吗？你不会自动从《但以关与魔狮》
We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. So you did the play, what happened? Did you start doing sketchcom? Like, you don't automatically go from Daniel and the Magic Lion. And playing Cedric. It was playing Cedric, the entertainer. And then all of a sudden, you're going to stand up
和扮演赛德里克过渡到单口喜剧，然后洛恩·迈尔斯就觉得你是下一个巨星。这到底是怎么发生的？你就这样登场了。你大提琴不拉了，对吧？你演了艾米·菲舍尔。你演了玛丽·乔。不，我是乔伊。哦，你是乔伊。
and you're in Lauren Michaels thinks you're the great next. Like, what happens? There you are. You're done playing the cello, right? You've played Amy Fisher. You played Mary Jo. No, I was Joey. Oh, you were Joey.
你是乔伊·巴塔福科。好吧。那个被贩卖的人。他被贩卖了。好吧。那然后呢，你做了什么？你去了纽约大学？你……
You were Joey, Butterfoot. Okay. Who was trafficking. He was trafficking. Okay. So then, what did you do? You go to NYU? What did you?
哥伦比亚大学。她是个聪明人。我去了那儿，但我，你知道的，我在高中时演过话剧。当然。我在哥伦比亚大学演过小品。然后我去试镜。我去参加了一个公开选秀，是为了一个节目，叫《大同性恋小品秀》（The Big Gay Sketch Show），当时在已经倒闭的Logo电视网上播出。
Columbia. She's a smarty. I went there, but I, you know, I did the plays in high school. Sure. And I did sketch at Columbia. And then I auditioned. I went to an open call for a show, the big gay sketch show, which was on the now-defunct logo network.
没错。没错。他们非常有才华的意大利人。开创性的。这是我们塞在剧院后方的一位意大利评论家。在过去的100多集里，他一直在经历被赶出去的过程。这从不显得老套，也从不搞笑。等等，所以《大同性恋小品秀》，那是……
That's right. That's right. They're very talented Italian. Groundbreaking. This is an Italian critic we have stuck in the back of the theater. It's been in the process of getting thrown out for over 100 episodes. It never gets old and never gets funny. Wait, so Big Kay Sketch Show, was that the...
所以那是我有生以来第一次去试镜的节目，然后我被录取了。我当时想……你当时多大？我22岁，我心想，嗯，这挺容易的。当然。然后我了解到，很显然这是一份艰难的职业。所以后来我在纽约的UCB待过，即Upright Citizens Brigade剧院（正直公民剧团），待了很多年。是的，没错。
So that was the first thing I ever auditioned for, and I got it. And I thought... How old were you? I was 22, and I thought, well, this will be easy. Sure. And then I learned, it became clear that it was a difficult career. And so then I did UCB in New York, the U.Rite Citizens Brigade Theater for many years. Yes, exactly.
然后我去试镜，什么？再说一遍，什么？我只想在这里停一下，关于UCB。我们说到第26集了。我们有人进进出出。威尔，可能你不是在那里遇到她的吧，威利？我没在那里见过你。我大概有12年每个星期天晚上都去那儿看Askat（UCB的即兴演出秀）。
And then I auditioned for, what? Say again, what? I just want to stop for one second here at UCB. We're on 26. We've got people coming in and out. Will probably, you didn't meet her there, Willie? I didn't see you there. I was there every Sunday night to ask at for about 12 years.
我甚至害怕去。去Askat。等等，Askat和UCB有什么区别？不，但你知道Askat。那是我们以前常去的周日晚上的演出。是的，这就像是一个婴儿期。
I was so afraid to even. Go to Askat. Wait, what's the difference between Askat and UCB? No, but you know Ascats. It's the Sunday night show that we used to go to. Yeah, it's like an infarcy.
这是一个即兴表演秀。马特和伊恩·罗伯茨以前经常演。那和UCB有什么区别？UCB是剧院。Askat是周日晚上的演出，就像是一个大型的、长篇的先驱秀。节目的名字。不管怎样，所以你当时太害怕而不敢去Askat，
It's an improv show. Matt and Ian Roberts used to do. What is the difference between that and UCB? UCB's the theater. Ascad was the Sunday night show, which was like a big long herald. The name of the show. Anyway, so you were too afraid to go to Ascot,
但是你当时在谁手下，你在一个喜剧团队里吗？还是说，和一个……我演小品，我还演了很多独角戏。哦。我有过……不，从来没有。而且我，我，但那涉及很多——我会有这样的经历，我做过一个表演，里面需要一个蛋糕、一整只烤鸡和七顶假发。
but who were you on, were you on a comedy team? Or, like, with a... I did sketch, and I did a lot of one-woman shows. Oh. And I had... No, never. And I, I, but that involved a lot of like, I would have, I did one where I had to, it had a cake in it and a full rotisserie chicken and seven wigs.
所以我必须把所有的假发都带上，然后我会在上面的格里斯蒂德（Gristedes）杂货店停下来，买一个蛋糕和一整只烤鸡，然后把它们带下去。所以我在搬运那些东西，那些日子是令人兴奋的日子，只是搬运了大量的道具和假发。我积攒了大约45顶假发，
And so I would have to bring all the wigs and then I would stop at the Gristides grocery store above and buy a cake and a full rotisserie chicken and bring them down. And so I was lugging those days, those days were exciting days and just lugging a lot of props and wigs. I had amassed a collection of 45 or so wigs that were
那些假发很恶心，里面还有鸡肉汁。它们沾满了鸡肉味，还沾满了蛋糕屑。但是当你回去时——非常快的插话，我21岁的时候去为《生动色彩》（In Living Color）试镜。所以这是一个名为“插话”的新环节。你继续。
gross and had chicken juice in them. They got all chickeny and they got all caky. But when you went back really quick sidebar, I had an audition for In Living Color when I was like 21. So a new segment called Sine. Go ahead.
我21岁的时候去为《生动色彩》试镜，为了取代，引述一下，“那个白人”，我当时对吗，和金·凯瑞一起，我拎着一大袋假发走进去，我坐下来，选角导演就坐在我正对面，我过了一遍我花大约24小时拼凑出来的所有这些角色，结果呢，没有一个人笑，没有一个人笑，然后她说，假发挺有趣的，不是吗？
I had auditioned for in living color when I was 21 years old to replace, quote, the white guy, is my right, with Jim Carrey, and I go in with a bag of tons of wigs, and I sit down, and the woman in the cast director sitting right across me, and I go through all these characters that I put together in like 24 hours, and at the end of it, not one laugh, not one laugh, and she goes, wigs are fun, aren't they?
哦，操。就这样。哦，肖尼。等一下。我必须，哦，不。等等。我完全不知道你有一大袋与一袋假发相匹配的角色。
Oh, fuck. And that's it. Oh, Shawnee. Wait a second. I had to, oh, no. Hang on. I had no idea that you had a bag of characters to match a bag of wigs.
我只是在想，我们能见识一个吗？对，我们能见识一下吗？给我们来个你最拿手的，肖尼。对不起，凯特，等一下。不，不，不，我也想要这个。给我们来个最棒的。我在24小时内把它们编出来了。我甚至不记得它们是什么了。
I just think, can we meet one? Yeah, can we meet? Give us your best one, Shawnee. Sorry, Kate, one sec. No, no, no, I want this, too. Give us your best. I made them up in 24 hours. I don't even remember what they are.
哦，天哪，你不记得了。你最拿手的是哪个？他来了。你好，老兄。那家伙头上可能挂着严重的刘海。对吧？好了，言归正传，凯特。所以，凯特，你刚才说当你在《大同性恋小品秀》或类似的节目时，
Oh, shit, you don't. What's your go-to? There he is. Hello, mate. That guy's probably got severe bangs. Right? All right, back to you, Kate. So, Kate, you said when you were in big gay sketch show or something,
你说，哦天哪，这真的好难。这和我想的不一样。你这话是什么意思？什么很难？就是当喜剧演员，当演员。我是说，你知道的，试镜什么的，找工作。你知道，非常，非常困难，而且要找到你的声音并开发素材。你知道的，这是一门毕生的手艺，你知道，练习这门手艺。
you said, oh boy, this was really hard. It's not what I thought it would be. What did you mean by that? What was hard? Just being a comedian, being an actor. I mean, you know, auditioning stuff, getting jobs. You know, very, very difficult and finding your voice and developing material. You know, this is a lifelong craft, you know, practicing the craft.
我以前很天真，而且，你知道的，结果发现这是一整套系统工程。是的。但很高兴。这很难。它不好驾驭。它比下午四点到六点之间的范威克高速公路（Van Wyck）还要难驾驭，我说的对吗？我说的对吗？我们在说范威克高速还是怎么着？
I thought I was naive and it's, you know, it turned out to be a whole thing. Yeah. But glad. It's hard. It's not easy to navigate. It's harder to navigate than the Van Wick between four and six, am I right? Am I right? Are we talking about the Van Wick or what?
你一路走南州公园大道（Southern State）吗？你平时怎么走？我不是疯子，但我有时会走贝尔公园大道（Belt Parkway）。我没撒谎。从肯尼迪机场（JFK）出来，我会走贝尔大道。哦，贝尔大道很棒，但你不能在贝尔大道上开半挂车。你不能在贝尔大道上开半挂车。然后我会走布鲁克林电池隧道（Brooklyn Battery Tunnel）。
You take the Southern State all the way? What do you do? I'm not a maniac, but I will sometimes take the Bell Parkway. I'm not lying. From JFK, I'll take the belt. Oh, the bell's great, but you can't put a semi-truck on the belt. You can't put a semi-truck on the belt. And then I'll take the Brooklyn Battery Tunnel.
真的。不，但真的，你得一路走长岛高速公路（LIE）离开那儿。很显然我走长岛高速。我又不是他妈的疯子。好吧，我不知道。我不了解你。在某个时候，你得换路线。凯特，去哥伦比亚大学的计划，去哥伦比亚大学的计划，
True. No, but really, you take the LIE all the way out of there. Obviously, I take the L.A. I'm not a fucking maniac. Well, I don't know. I don't know you. At some point, you're switching. Kate, the plan going to Columbia, the plan going to Columbia,
既然你主修戏剧并获得了学位，那么打算是以演员为生，对吗？这就是你养活自己的方式吗？不，我没有，我做梦也没想到那是可能的。我简直不敢相信。你是个聪明人，凭借着……去上哥伦比亚大学。你主修戏剧。你带着那里的学位毕业。你当时是怎么打算跨行到一个完全不同的行业去养活自己并提供住所的？
since you majored, graduated with a degree in theater, was to be an actor as you're living, correct? This was how you're going to feed yourself. No, I did not, I never in my wildest dreams imagined that that was possible. I can't believe that. You're a smart person by virtue of. going to Columbia. You major in theater. You come out with a degree there. How were you planning that you were going to tack to a completely different industry to feed yourself and provide shelter?
我大学毕业那个夏天，我的计划是打扮成“长袜子皮皮”（Pippi Longstocking）去联合广场（Union Square）卖冰棒。我的噱头就是我会打扮成“长袜子皮皮”。这样每个人都会买我的冰棒。这就是我那个夏天的职业规划。冰棒有着巨大的利润空间。我也真的很想去罗马尼亚或某个巴尔干国家教英语。或者去英国教罗马尼亚语？是的。
The summer I graduated from college, my plan was that I was going to dress up as Pippi Longstocking and sell popsicles in Union Square. And my gimmick would be that I would be dressed as Pippi Longstocking. And so everyone would buy my popsicles. So that was my professional plan that summer. Great markup potential on popsicles. I also was really wanting to teach English in Romania or one of the Balkan states. Or Romanian in England? Yes.
等等，等等，所以你没有想象过？我觉得这太——我的意思是，你一定知道，连肖恩·海耶斯都觉得自己能在娱乐圈混出名堂，带着他的假发。我现在正戴着一个呢。我从来、从来、从来没想过那是可能的，不，好吧，那SNL的试镜是怎么回事呢？
Wait, wait, so you didn't imagine it? I find that so, I mean, you must have known that even Sean Hayes thought he could make it in show business. with his wigs I got one on now never did I ever ever think that that was possible no okay so how did the audition for SNL happen then
你当时在UCB，就像林赛·舒库斯（Lindsay Shookus）下来看你演出，然后发生了什么？我在洛杉矶做一场展演，他们邀请我去试镜，然后我去了。
you were at UCB you did like Lindsay shook us came down and saw you what happened I was doing a showcase in L.A. and they invited me to audition and then I did
试镜进行得怎么样？我猜你当时非常紧张。我紧张得要命。我……频繁地去洗手间。频繁地去洗手间。不，我紧张得要命，但后来鲍比·莫伊尼汉（Bobby Moynihan）——我猜他可能在UCB看过我演的独角戏——他走到我面前对我说，嘿，你很有趣，然后……然后我能呼吸了，就是这样。所以我把一切都归功于他。在关键时刻给你打了一剂强心针。不，但说真的，你知道，就在黑暗中有人向你伸出援手时。
that audition go? You were very nervous, I would imagine. I was horrifically nervous. I was going to... The restroom often. The restroom often. No, I was horrendously nervous, but then Bobby Moynihan, I guess maybe had seen me at UCB doing a one-woman show and he came up to me and he said, hey, you're funny and I... And then I could breathe and that was it. So I do credit him with everything. Giving you a little prop up right beforehand. No, but seriously, like, you know, just when someone reaches out to you in the dark.
她来了。你知道的，有时候，只需要一个人。懂的。因为当某人有这份善良去看到你。说得好。然后你就长高了一点。你就能飞了。是的，我们马上回来。
Here she comes. You know, and some, all it takes is one. Get it. Because when someone has the kindness to see you. Preach it. Then you get a little bit taller. And you can fly. Yep, we're going to be right back.
流感——不，但不是——如果他当时没那么做，老实说，我——我会身在罗马尼亚，而他们对你反响很好吗？黑暗中的人们发出了慷慨的笑声和温暖吗？我听到了一些——呃，轻笑，轻微的窃笑，这太鼓舞人心了，因为我听说那里会是一片死寂，所以我已经做好了死寂的准备。是的，当我听到一声轻笑时，我想，好吧，我在飞了。不过我也排练了很多，就像我喜欢临场发挥一样。
flu um no but no if if he had not done that honestly i i would be uh in romania and they received you well was it was there was a generous laughter and warmth from the people in the dark i heard some uh titters mild titters which was so encouraging because i had heard that there there would be dead silence so i was prepared for dead silence yeah and then when i got a single titter i thought okay I'm flying but I had also practiced it a lot like I like to wing stuff
我不知道你们怎么样，但我想——我一直在听这个节目，我已经没有问题了，他们不会当场让你知道结果的，对吧？他们会给你打电话吗？你的经纪人会打电话吗？我们当时有经纪人代表吗？
I don't know about you guys but that I thought I've been listening to the show I'm all out of questions now do they they don't let you know on the spot there right do they call you does your agent call you are we represented at that moment
由经纪人代表？我当时觉得我没有代表——我想我没有——不对，这不是真的，我有，我有，我有经纪人，也有经理，在那时候——上帝保佑。所以——所以你接到了电话，你很激动，你很紧张，你去了，你去了——SNL的第一天是什么样的？是你想象的那样吗？谁——嗯，我当时——伙计们，我只是真的，真的很紧张，当然他们所有人也都是。哦，好吧，所以——
by an agent I don't think I did at that point have represented i i think i had no that's not true i did i did have i did have i did have an agent and a manager at that point um bless and so and so you get the call you're related you're you're you're nervous you go you go to you go what was a first day like over there at at s and l was it what you what you thought it might be who um it was i got guys i just was really really nervous and sure they all were oh well well so So the thing was it was just me.
情况就是只有我一个人。我是作为一个新人，在一季的最后五集时被单独招进去的。所以我当时就像，这是你的电脑。谢天谢地，我在UCB认识了那里的几个人，他们把我从我自己紧张情绪的汹涌波涛中解救出来，真正帮了我一把。你是编剧还是演员？演员。演员，一出道就是演员。
I was hired alone at the last five episodes of a season. So I just, I was like, here's your computer. And bless them, I had known a few folks there from UCB who rescued me from the choppy, choppy waters of my own nervousness and really helped me out. Were you writer or performer? Performer. Performer, right out of the gate.
我只是想说，对于那场试镜，我排练了太多次了。我一定把那个台词大声说了五万遍。我觉得感觉还不错，因为我做了那些准备。但通常我都是在临场发挥。我觉得那些真正脱颖而出的表演者——我是说，你们告诉我，因为我只主持过一次，我从来不是固定演员，
I just want to say, like, with that audition, like, I practiced so many times. I must have said that out loud 50,000 times. And I felt okay about it because I had done that. But usually I'm winging it. I feel like the performers that really stand, I mean, you tell me, because I only hosted once, I've never been a cast member,
但从我看到的来看，那些在《周六夜现场》中真正脱颖而出的演员，真的做了功课，并且真正投入到角色或对话中，因为很多时候我看不出你在看提词卡，你那么投入其中，我看不出你在看提词卡，而很多人我确实能看到他们在看提词卡，而且无论你，每个人这两种都做，但这里面有任何一点是真的吗，就是你记了很多台词，而不是依赖提词卡？你个人而言，我无法记住台词，我曾经拥有的任何能力……都随着我对那些可爱提词卡的依赖而离我远去了，现在我无法记忆了，我也忘了。
but from what I see is the people that really stand out on Saturday Night Live really do their homework and really work on characters or the dialogue because a lot of the times I can't see you reading the cards like you're so in it I don't see you reading the cards and a lot of people I do see read the cards and both you know everybody does both but is that any of that true that you memorize a lot of the stuff as opposed to rely on the cards you personally I cannot memorize dialogue I whatever ability I ever had um left with my reliance on those cute cards and now I cannot memorize and I forget
我记不住东西了。我不会再向沃利（Wally）致谢了，在这个节目里我们已经谢过太多次了，所以我不打算再谢他，但他是一个了不起的提词卡制作人。他是一个了不起的提词卡艺术家。你怀念它吗，凯特，一点也不吗？
I'm just I can't remember stuff anymore I'm not going to give another shout out to Wally we've done it too many times on this show so I'm not going to do it but he is an incredible card he is an incredible card artist do you miss it Kate at all
我怀念。我怀念那些人，我怀念沃利，我怀念舞台经理珍娜（Jenna）和克里斯（Chris），我太怀念我所有的朋友了。我怀念洛恩·迈尔斯。是的，我怀念它。我怀念，我怀念能够参与对时事进行评论的能力。但我也为能在10点半上床睡觉感到由衷的高兴，那本该是我通常睡觉的时间。随着你的才华、自信、
I do I miss I miss the people I miss Wally I miss Jenna and Chris the stage manager so much I miss all of my friends. I miss Lorne Michaels. And yes, I miss it. And I miss, I miss being able to participate in commenting on current events. But I also am so happy to be going to bed at 10.30, which is when I would normally go to bed. Did it get harder or easier as your talent, confidence?
知名度不断提高，这变得更难了还是更容易了？你可能会觉得它应该变得更容易，但也许它变得更难了，因为你知道人们在看着你？期望？它一直都很难，也一直都很有趣。是的。不管怎样，人们通常就是这样形容肖恩的。
popularity increased. You'd think it would get easier, but maybe it gets harder because you know people are watching you? Expectation? It was always hard and always fun. Yeah. Anyway, it's the way people often describe Sean.
你知道的，对吧？通常很难。总是很难，也总是很有趣。那就是我。我想那是他在高中时的座右铭，我想是的。我是说，对，对，对。我知道，对不起，对不起，这简直就是他妈的一场碰运气游戏，凯特。
You know that, right? Often hard. Always hard and always fun. That's me. That was his candle in high school, I think. I mean, yeah, yeah, yeah. I know, sorry, sorry, it's just like, it's just a fucking crap shoot over here, Kate.
听着，我们不想带你走回忆之旅，但我们不得不这么做，因为我们想了解你。我们想了解。让我们现在把SNL的一切快进到底。好吧，让我们来到SNL的结尾，我们做出了继续前进的决定。虽然令人害怕，但取得了巨大的成功，对吧？昂首阔步地走出大门，然后——然后——然后——然后——现在你正飞黄腾达，而且——但我敢打赌，一开始还是有点儿
Look, we don't want to take you down memory lane, but we have to, because we want to get to know you. We want to know. Let's shuttle all the way through S&L now. Okay, let's get to the end of S&L, and we make the decision to move on. Frightening, but great success, right? out the door and uh and and and and and and now you're flying high and um but i bet it was a a little
有点让人神经紧张的，对吧？哦，简直——我——我不喜欢改变，所以这——简直太糟糕了，我就是讨厌——我讨厌离别，我讨厌改变，所以——这不是一个轻易做出的决定，而且我太难过了，我就是太难过了，而且——真的真的很想念——我共事过的每一个人，因为这是一个美丽的大家庭，它是——太棒了，这感觉就像橄榄园（Olive Garden）餐厅一样，对吧？对，对，对，挺好的，不过我——但我当时想要——当你身处其中时，当你身处其中时，你在吃面包棒，而且他们也有那种无限量的面包——等等，什么，你是——你是——你在做这个的同时还在写书吗？
a little nerve-wracking at the beginning right oh just just i don't i don't like change and so it was um just terrible i just i hate i hate goodbyes i hate change and so um it was uh not a decision made lightly and i was just so sad i just was so sad and um really do miss uh everybody that i worked with because it's it's a beautiful it's such a family and it's uh it's wonderful and i it's like olive garden that place right yeah yeah yeah good like but i um but then i i wanted to when you're there when you're there you are eating breadsticks and plus they do have also like unlimited bread What about, what, were you, were you, were you, were you writing books at while you were doing this?
开始的时候有点让人伤脑筋，对吧？哦，我就是……我就是不喜欢改变，所以这……简直太糟糕了。我就是讨厌，我讨厌离别，我讨厌改变，所以……这并不是一个轻易做出的决定，我当时真的太难过了，我真的太难过了，而且……真的很想念和我一起工作的每个人，因为那是一个美好的、就像一个大家庭一样的地方，非常棒。而且，那就像橄榄园餐厅一样，对吧？对，对，对，就像……但是，我……然后我想，当你坐在那里的时候，你就在吃面包棒，而且他们还有无限量的面包。话说回来，你在做这些的时候，是不是一直在写书？
Where, where, where, where, where, where, where, oh, that was just, that was something that I started doing to, uh, when I, like, wasn't at S&L, I just, I, I, I, I, I always loved, you know, I love, I love characters. Oh, sure. I love big hair and I love, uh, funny names. Sashimi. Sashimi. Sashimi. Sashimi. And we will be right back.
哪个，哪个，哪个，哪个，哪个，哪个，哪个，哦，那只是，那是我开始做的一件事，呃，当我，比如，不在周六夜现场的时候，我只是，我，我，我，我，我，我一直很喜欢，你知道，我喜欢，我喜欢角色。哦，当然。我喜欢蓬松的头发，我喜欢，呃，搞笑的名字。生鱼片。生鱼片。生鱼片。生鱼片。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. Can I ask you a serious question? What about, what about being? Yeah, I got to come in. I got to get in there. So the big gay sketch show, you were obviously gay and out because you're on a show called The Big Gay Sketch Show. But then when you went into Scenarian Live,
现在，回到节目中。我能问你一个严肃的问题吗？关于，关于存在？对，我得插话。我得加入。所以《同志大招牌》（The Big Gay Sketch Show），你显然是公开的同性恋，因为你参加了一个叫《同志大招牌》的节目。但后来当你进入《周六夜现场》时，
did you have, were you out and proud? Or was it something you struggled with keeping a secret? Or am I an idiot and you were out? and I just didn't know, or did that play an impact or not? Bless your heart. Bless your heart. No, I was out. I was, it was on the internet. Okay, great. So it must be true. It was on the internet in 2006. So there, there it was. And, um, and I'm glad. I'm glad it was because No pun. No pun on the glad thing. Mm-hmm. For Tracy, glad is a LGBTQ organization. Because it was, it was already, it was already done. And I, I, I, so I, uh,
你有，你是公开且引以为傲的吗？还是说你曾为保守这个秘密而挣扎过？或者我是个白痴，而你其实是公开的，我只是不知道，还是说这发挥了什么影响，没有吗？老天保佑你。老天保佑你。不，我是公开的。我是，这在互联网上。好吧，太棒了。所以这一定是真的。2006年在互联网上。所以，它就在那里。而且，呃，我很高兴。我很高兴它是，因为——没有双关语。对“同道”（GLAAD）这个名字没有双关语。嗯哼。对于“同道”来说，这是一个LGBTQ组织。因为它是，它已经，它已经完成了。而我，我，我，所以我，呃，
You know, I am a coward, and I don't know if I would have had the courage to do it if I had not already done it. I would have, I would have had to. But then did you, did you, does my Wikipedia research accurate? Did you, you confirmed all when you gave Ellen an award and thanked her for blazing the trail of kicking the door down? Question? I did, I think it was pretty obvious the whole time. I did give Ellen that award, yes. Okay.
你知道，我是一个懦夫，我不知道如果我还没有做过这件事，我是否有勇气去做。我本会，我本不得不这样做。但后来你，你，我的维基百科研究准确吗？你，你给埃伦（Ellen）颁奖并感谢她开拓了破门而入的道路时，你证实了这一切？有问题吗？我证实了，我觉得整个过程挺明显的。我确实给埃伦颁了那个奖，是的。好的。
Wiki really framed that as a pivotal moment. Well, okay, okay. I thought I was gay, gay before that, but that's cool. No, that's interesting. No, they're trying to claim it. Beyonce was at my table that night. Beyonce was? Yes, and she was wearing a dress that was so...
维基确实把它塑造成了一个关键时刻。好吧，好吧，好吧。我以为我在这之前就是同性恋，是同性恋，但这很酷。不，这很有趣。不，他们正试图声称这一点。碧昂丝那天晚上在我的桌子旁。碧昂丝在？对，她穿着一件裙子，那么……
Nice, nice, the shoulders were so tall. and I don't know how she saw to her left or to her right oh wow I guess she didn't need to she was so resplendent she was so I couldn't look at her well the confidence to just know
漂亮，漂亮，肩膀好高。而且我不知道她是怎么看左边或右边的，哦，哇，我想她不需要看。她太光彩照人了，她太……我无法直视她。那种自信，让你只知道
that you only need to look forward that really speaks to a level of confidence that you're not worried about what's on either side it's all a smooth sailing it's everything's wide open wider than
你只需要向前看，这确实说明了一种自信的水平，你不用担心两边是什么，一切都一帆风顺，一切都是开阔的，比
the Grand Central Park we had Monday at 10 p.m. Just nothing. It's great. It's great. These callbacks, you got to keep your knees bent, Kate.
我们在周一晚上10点看到的中央公园还要开阔。什么都没有。太棒了。太棒了。这些包袱，你得保持膝盖微屈，凯特。
He'll keep coming. Do you think, do you think, so stupid. I mean, before it turns into the northern state, sure.
他会源源不断地来。你觉得，你觉得，太蠢了。我是说，在它变成北方州之前，当然。
Obviously. Obvious. Now, do you think that... The Tri-Brow is my favorite bridge. I don't know about you. I do. I like the Triborough.
显然。显然。现在，你觉得……三区大桥（Tri-Brow）是我最喜欢的桥。我不知道你怎么想。我是。我喜欢三区大桥。
Not the GW. No. Tap and Z. Trash. That's way too far in north. What's not called Cuomo now? Hey, you know what's kind of underrated is the Queensboro? I love, I also love the Queensboro Bridge is pretty good.
不是华盛顿大桥。不。塔潘泽大桥。垃圾。那太偏北了。现在不叫科莫（Cuomo）桥了吗？嘿，你知道什么被严重低估了吗，皇后区大桥（Queensboro）？我喜欢，我也喜欢皇后区大桥，挺不错的。
Also referred to as the Midtown Bridge or the 52nd Street Bridge. No, no. Never referred to as that. So, Kate, I don't know what, he's up in Midtown. It is up in, it's the one that empties out right by Silvercombe. I could talk parkways with you all day, Will. All day. I really could.
也被称为中城大桥（Midtown Bridge）或52街大桥。不，不。从来不叫这个。所以，凯特，我不知道什么，他在中城。它确实在，就是那个在银科姆（Silvercombe）附近卸载的桥。我可以跟你聊一整天的高速公路，威尔。一整天。我真的可以。
This is fun stuff. Oh, you love the cross Bronx, Express right? Yeah. Oh, I do like the cross Bronx. And what is the name of the Polish bridge, Kyanoski or whatever? Pulaski. Kishu-Laski Bridge that's on the BQE.
这很有趣。哦，你喜欢跨布朗克斯（Cross Bronx）快车道，对吧？对。哦，我确实喜欢跨布朗克斯。那个波兰大桥叫什么名字，基亚诺斯基还是什么的？普拉斯基（Pulaski）。基舒-拉斯基大桥，在布鲁克林-皇后区高速公路（BQE）上。
Yeah. That's the Pulaski. She's got the first word. No, is that right? Yeah. She's got the first name. Oh, I'm sorry. This Kishkuzko is into Greenpoint.
对。那是普拉斯基。她拿了第一个词。不，是这样吗？对。她拿了第一个名字。哦，对不起。这个基斯库斯科（Kosciuszko）通往绿点（Greenpoint）。
Am I thinking of the wrong bridge? No, I think you're thinking of the wrong. Say it one more time. Kiskechko. Will, you know what I'm talking, help me up. It's all lit up. now. They've got nice colored lights on it. Reach in and rescue me.
我是不是想错桥了？不，我觉得你想错了。再说一遍。基斯库斯科。威尔，你知道我在说什么，帮帮我。它现在全亮了。上面有漂亮的彩灯。伸手把我救出来。
Oh, oh, oh. Is it not a bridge? It is a bridge. But it's an inter-Brooklyn bridge, though, right? This is chaos. Yes, I, yes, yes, yes. We're in a four-wheel slide here on the Christian mission. This is pure chaos, you guys.
哦，哦，哦。它不是一座桥吗？它是一座桥。但它是一座跨布鲁克林的大桥，对吧？这简直是一团糟。是的，我，是的，是的，是的。我们在基督教宣教团这里来了个四轮侧滑。这纯粹是一团糟，你们。
A, uh, you know, you know, Kate, here on my question list. No, you're right, it's the Casisco, it's the Casisco bridge. No, that's on the BQE. Sure. Right? That's the, that's the one that's on the BQE, the Cizzoe, the Cizcoe, the Cusisco Bridge. Thank you because I thought
呃，你知道，你知道，凯特，在我问题清单上的。不，你说得对，是基斯库斯科，是基斯库斯科桥。不，那在BQE上。对吧？那是，那是BQE上的那个，西佐，西斯科，库斯斯科桥。谢谢你，因为我以为
I have lost my marbles. You're right. Can I come off? Anyway, all right. So guys. On the Pulaski, we're, let's take a look at the live
我已经疯了。你说得对。我能下来吗？不管怎样，好吧。所以，各位。在普拉斯基桥上，我们，让我们看看实时
traffic if we could. Where's the Veritza? You know, by the way, a little sidebar here. I'd like to start a side hustle. I'd like to see
交通状况，如果可以的话。韦拉扎诺（Verrazzano）大桥在哪？顺便说一句，插一句题外话。我想开始一个副业。我想看看
Will Arnett hosts our night live. Oh, man. You could get that momentum going? You never have, Will? I know, would you love to see. Geez, Louisville, that would be incredible. What about for the movie coming out?
威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）主持我们的《周六夜现场》。哦，天哪。你能把那个势头带动起来吗？你从来没有过吗，威尔？我知道，你会喜欢看到的。天哪，路易斯维尔，那太不可思议了。新电影上映时怎么样？
Yes, for the movie coming out. It's been too long. It's been too long. Who's running things over there now? Lindsay is she still there? No. No? Well, whoever is in there.
对，为了即将上映的电影。太久了。太久了。现在是谁在那边掌权？林赛还在那儿吗？不在。不在？好吧，不管是谁在那里。
Let's get Arnett over there. At least as a musical guest. It's too much. The history is too storied. No, they love that over there. It makes it for a great story. Anyway. Bring your bongos, Will, and just play the music.
让阿奈特去那儿吧。至少作为音乐嘉宾。太多了。历史太丰富了。不，他们喜欢那边的那种事。这能造就一个伟大的故事。不管怎样。带上你的邦戈鼓，威尔，直接演奏音乐。
Who told you about the bongos? I gave you those. Hey, if you couldn't. You did give me those. Kate, if you weren't a New York Times bestselling author or America's sweetheart on the TV or film, let's not forget about the film jobs, what would you be doing?
谁跟你说过邦戈鼓的事？我送给你的啊。嘿，如果你不能。你确实送过我。凯特，如果你不是《纽约时报》畅销书作家，也不是电视或电影里美国的甜心——别忘了电影工作——你会做什么？
Carpentry. Truly? Really? You and Nick Offerman. Yeah. Really? And John Stewart, they say. I, no, it's a thing that, yeah,
木工。真的吗？真的吗？你和尼克·奥弗曼（Nick Offerman）。对。真的吗？还有约翰·斯图尔特（John Stewart），他们说。我，不，这是一件事，是的，
folks are doing carpentry and so on. am I and I'm doing it and that's what but I always said I have always said I know you have that I would make cabinets that I would want to make cabinets it's true and you threatened the world with that no it's start with the whole wiki page starts that and I and I and I and I now I have made a cabinet is that true a real cat yes I have do you do an Amish style with no nails no not that good I'm not a carpenter it sounds like we're upstate when we're making cabinet a tree? Sure thing.
大家都在做木工之类的。我是，我在做，这就是，但我总是说，我一直都说，我知道你有，我会做橱柜，我想做橱柜，这是真的，你用这个威胁全世界，不，整个维基百科页面就是从这开始的，我，我，我，我，现在我做了一个橱柜，真的吗，一个真正的柜子，是的，我做过，你做的是无钉的阿米什风格吗？不，没那么好，我不是个木匠，当我们做柜子的时候，听起来我们像是在北部州，一棵树？当然。
Sure. So you got like a handsome old farm, like a barn up there that you've kind of refurbished. It's fine. Sure, no, I'll bet it's good. I've got a garage and I got a bunch of stuff in there. Tools? A bunch of stuff going on. Yeah.
当然。所以你有一个漂亮的旧农场，比如北边的一个你翻新过的谷仓。挺好的。当然，不，我敢说它很好。我有一个车库，里面有一堆东西。工具？一堆东西在里面。对。
So that's my new. So when I... You got a workshop in the garage? Yeah, I got a workshop. Yeah. You got a workshop? You've got a bench and you've got a bunch of power tools and things like that. I bet there's fun to buy.
所以那是我的新。所以当我……你车库里有个工作室？对，我有个工作室。对。你有个工作室？你有一个工作台，还有一堆电动工具之类的东西。我敢说买这些很有趣。
I have a lot. You love a Home Depot? I go to Lowe's. I have a local loss. And, yeah, that's what I... So when I left S&L, I needed to know that I was jumping to something, which was making cabinets, and that's what I have done in my spare time. And you've just done the one so far?
我有很多。你喜欢家得宝（Home Depot）？我去劳氏（Lowe's）。我有当地的劳氏。而且，是的，这就是我……所以当我离开《周六夜现场》时，我需要知道我要转行去做点什么，那就是做橱柜，这就是我在业余时间所做的事情。你到目前为止只做一个吗？
I've done a bunch of stuff. Okay, you don't need to scream. What's your favorite... Are you most proud of the cabinet? No, we nailed it. Sorry, go ahead. That was just a quick word From the gang over at Lowe
我做了一堆东西。好了，你不用尖叫。你最喜欢的是……你最为这个柜子感到骄傲吗？不，我们做得很棒。抱歉，你继续。那只是来自劳氏那边的一群人的简短留言
That just came through on my text I'm so sorry I'm fucking shameless guys I'm sorry I just made $4,200 bucks Oh Wait Kate Do you have a certain thing
刚刚发到了我的短信里我太抱歉了，我真他妈不要脸，伙计们，对不起，我刚刚赚了4200美元哦等等凯特你有某种
In woodworking That you feel like You're your best at You know? Trim Molding Penalding Okay sorry
木工手艺是你觉得你最擅长的吗？你知道吗？饰条、造型、镶板。好吧，抱歉。
Different Sorry okay Hey Kate By the way this book, so I have a five-year-old. Yeah. Is this book going to be appropriate for my five-year-old? Okay, so the books, okay, so we, you know, I was joking before about the book being
不同，抱歉，好吧。嘿，凯特，顺便问一下，这本书，我有一个五岁的孩子。是的。这本书适合我五岁的孩子吗？好吧，关于书，我们，你知道，我之前开玩笑说这本书
about a diver named Natalie. That's not true. The book is the second in a, it's the second book in a series of books called the Millicent Quibb School of Etiquette for Young Ladies of Mad Science, okay? And it's a middle grade novel, which is for ages, you know, eight, to 14 Harry Potter is a middle grade novel
是关于一个叫娜塔莉的潜水员的。那不是真的。这本书是第二本，这是一个系列书中的第二本，书名叫《米利森特·奎布的年轻淑女疯狂科学礼仪学校》，好吧？这是一部中级小说，适合，你知道的，8到14岁的孩子。哈利·波特是一部中级小说。
heard of it anyway so Raul Dahl was a middle grade author heard of them yeah and of course
听说过吧？不管怎样，罗尔德·达尔（Roald Dahl）是一位中级儿童文学作家，听说过他们吧？对，当然
so this no so I started writing this book I came up with this idea with these characters like 10 years ago and whenever I wasn't at S&L I would be writing
所以这，不，所以我开始写这本书，我大约10年前就想出了这个点子，有了这些角色，每当我不在《周六夜现场》的时候，我就会写
this thing and then so when I finished us and help finally i had time to complete what happens when she starts talking fast you guys the novel and um and so this so the secrets of the purple pearl is the second in the millicent quibb series and it's about a mad scientist who starts a school for girls and a repressive turn of the century town and then in the second one the purple pearl you know they're at a hotel and they're having an adventure and they're looking for a purple pearl no i do like those i do like those
这个东西，然后当我终于离开《周六夜现场》时，我有时间完成——当她开始语速变快时会发生什么，伙计们——这部小说，嗯，所以这个，紫珍珠的秘密是米利森特·奎布系列的第二本，讲的是一个疯狂科学家在一个压抑的世纪之交小镇为女孩们创办了一所学校，然后在第二本《紫珍珠》里，你知道的，他们在一家酒店里，经历了一场冒险，他们在寻找一颗紫珍珠。不，我确实喜欢那些，我确实喜欢那些
those books are What? The middle, what's it called? Middle grade? Middle grade. Middle grade. Middle grade books are very important to get kids. I read Harry Potter
那些书是，什么？中级，叫什么？中级？中级。中级读物对于吸引孩子非常重要。我读过《哈利·波特》
when it first came out of the 90s because I was like, what's going on the hub of this? I want to kind of know. In between your Holocaust books? In between World War II? I mean, this guy, you have any questions on World War II
当它在90年代刚出来的时候，因为我想，这到底是怎么回事？我有点想知道。在你的大屠杀书籍之间？在第二次世界大战之间？我是说，这家伙，你对二战有什么问题
bring him to Willie A. That's a true story. You know what? I'm not reading World War II stuff anymore. Oh. What would have moved on to? Some sort of... I just finished.
去找威利·A（Willie A.）。这是一个真实的故事。你知道吗？我不再读二战的东西了。哦。你转向什么了？某种……我刚读完。
He knows the ending. I do. I just read this book about the siege of Mecca that was a couple weeks ago and then I read Freedom by Jonathan Frenzen. That was really good. It's a little, it's older, but I just read it recently. That's fiction though, yeah, for instance? Yeah, yeah. So it's really sort of brought in my horizon recently. Thank you. Were you writing, were you writing when you were like at SNL instead, or did you have designs on writing literature in this way? Yes, I wanted to. I really, I wanted to be a, a Y-A, no, a middle-grade novelist.
他知道结局。我确实知道。我几周前刚读完一本关于麦加围城战的书，然后我读了乔纳森·弗兰岑（Jonathan Franzen）的《自由》（Freedom）。那真的很棒。它有点，它是旧书，但我最近刚读过。那是小说，对吧，弗兰岑的？对，对。所以这确实在最近开阔了我的眼界。谢谢。你在的时候，你在像《周六夜现场》的时候也在写作吗，还是说你当时就想以这种方式创作文学？是的，我想。我真的很想成为一名，青年——不，一名中级小说家。
But Y. Okay, so middle-grade, so the thing about Y-A is it's like monsters and making out. Love that. Middle grade is fantasy. It's discovering your identity. It's grappling with questions of do you want to be, how do you want to appear in the world? Who are you? What are you for?
但是青年小说。好吧，所以中级读物，青年小说的特点是里面有怪物和亲热。喜欢这个。中级读物是奇幻的。它是关于发现你的身份。它是在与这些问题搏斗：你想成为什么样的人？你想以什么形象出现在世界上？你是谁？你是为何而存在的？
Right. What are you fighting for? What are you willing to sacrifice to fight? for it. These are the questions of middle grade and so I'm very drawn to the genre. Also these books can be really funny and they and people
对。你在为什么而战？你愿意为了战斗牺牲什么？为了它。这些都是中级读物探讨的问题，所以我非常被这个流派吸引。而且这些书籍可以非常有趣，它们而且人们
characters can have really good funny names and I think names and hair and funny voice are the most important that does a character make. Now what about the illustrations then in these books? How
角色可以有非常好笑的名字，我认为名字、发型和有趣的嗓音是一个角色最重要的构成要素。那么这些书里的插画呢？你参与
involved with you with that are you? I would say that I was involved, the illustrator is a beautiful artist named Alfredo Caceres and he did such a beautiful art. I did have like ideas of what the stuff, you know, because it's imagination. And I could see it in my mind.
的程度有多深？我想说我参与了，插画师是一位才华横溢的艺术家，名叫阿尔弗雷多·卡萨雷斯（Alfredo Caceres），他画的艺术作品太美了。我确实有一些关于东西的想法，你知道的，因为这是想象力。我能在脑海中看到它。
So I made little doodles and then he made beautiful art. Right. So you had some notes. And was Alfredo amenable to your notes? Or was that an interesting creative negotiation? It was a beautiful collaborative process. and he's um it was wonderful okay i i described and he created yeah kate mckenon it's a monday and you have to talk to us donkeys and then you hang up you leave you leave the publishers the house okay okay uh some of my favorite comedians yeah what's the rest of your eyes closed you keep
所以我画了一些小涂鸦，然后他创作出了美丽的艺术品。对。所以你有一些意见。阿尔弗雷多能接受你的意见吗？还是说那是一次有趣的创意协商？那是一个美丽的合作过程。而且他，呃，非常棒。好吧，我描述，他创作。是的，凯特·麦金农，今天是星期周一，你得跟我们这些笨蛋说话，然后你挂断，你离开，你离开出版商的办公室，好吧，好吧，呃，我最喜欢的一些喜剧演员， yeah，你的眼睛是怎么回事，你一直
closing your eyes when you say that what kate when you leave when you leave the publisher's office where do you go what do you do on a monday like today had you not been doing this. What are you doing? Well, it's hot in New York. She's going to Union Square to sling popsicles, right? No, but I mean are you going to the movies? Are you going to a bookstore? Are you going for lunch? Are you watching reality TV? What are you doing? This is the thing we want to know about Kim
闭着眼睛，当你这么说的时候，凯特，当你离开，当你离开出版商办公室的时候，你去哪里？像今天这样的周一，如果你没做这个，你会在做什么？你在做什么？好吧，纽约天气很热。她要去联合广场（Union Square）叫卖冰棒，对吧？不，我的意思是，你要去看电影吗？你要去书店吗？你要去吃午饭吗？你在看真人秀吗？你在做什么？这是我们想知道的关于凯特
McKinnon. Okay? Let's get inside the mind. What are you doing? I do, well, I'm going to be doing some stone masonry later, but that's another story. I do watch a lot of reality television. Oh, what's your favorite? Wait, are you a Love Island girl? Or are you an alone girl? I have done all of that
麦金农的事情。好吧？让我们走进她的内心。你在做什么？我，好吧，我待会儿要做一些石工活，但那是另一回事了。我确实看很多真人秀电视节目。哦，你最喜欢哪个？等等，你是《求爱岛》（Love Island）女孩？还是《荒野独居》（Alone）女孩？我都看过
Try Outlast on Netflix Outlast Yeah, listen, I mean, you know Oh, you did that's good Yeah, it's fun It's like a combo between alone and Survivor I really like that Yeah, that's an aggregate show. Yeah, yeah, that's cool
Netflix的《生存极限》（Outlast）看过吗？《生存极限》对吧，听着，我的意思是，你知道哦，你看了，那很好对，这很有趣它有点介于《荒野独居》和《幸存者》（Survivor）之间我真的很喜欢那个对，那是个综合节目。对，对，那是个综合好去处。对，对，我们有个新节目要上映了哇，你真是涉足很多领域啊
That's an aggregate joint Yeah, yeah, we got a new one coming out Wow, you got your hands in a lot of pies Yeah, well that got him in so much trouble Obviously back in the day So then, so you're going to... You're licking cherries off your stuff. Wow.
对，嗯，这让他惹上了大麻烦，显然在过去。所以，然后，你要……你在舔你身上的樱桃。哇。
So wait, so we're driving back upstate in your Volvo stage? In the Volvo stage. Prius. And a Prius? Prius hybrid. Okay. Good for you. And you'll be there by, you'll be there...
所以等等，所以我们要开着你的沃尔沃轿车回北部州？开着沃尔沃轿车。普锐斯。还有一辆普锐斯？普锐斯混合动力车。好吧。真不错。你大概在，你会在……
You'll be there at 435. Well, that depends on the traffic on the G-Dub. Are you a cooker, or do you like to order in? I cook every day three times. the day. This is an honest podcast. Is that true? I cook every day three times a day.
你会在4点35分到。嗯，这取决于华盛顿大桥（G-Dub）上的交通状况。你是个会做饭的人，还是喜欢叫外卖？我每天做饭三次。每天。这是一个诚实的播客。真的吗？我每天做饭三次。
I must. What's the most, what's the thing that you cook the most frequently for yourself? Yeah, you go to. What's you go to? I cook, I, you know, I've become a gardener, big gardener. Okay. And I, um, you got veggies. So I make, I just chop up whatever I've got.
我必须这么做。你给自己做得最频繁的菜是什么？对，你的拿手菜。你的拿手菜是什么？我做饭，我，你知道的，我成了个园丁，一个大园丁。好吧。然后我，呃，你有蔬菜。所以我做，我只是把我有的任何东西切碎。
And I just, I do it. Yeah. And plant parmesan. Yeah. Yeah? That's what I do. Oh my God. A meelage, a vegetable meelage over whatever I got.
然后我就做了。对。还有植物帕尔马干酪。对。对吧？这就是我做的。天哪。杂烩，把各种蔬菜杂烩在一起做成我有的东西。
I got a question for you, and I want you to be honest with me of this. Yeah, yeah. Okay. Whitestone or Throg's Neck Bridge? If you're going to Westchester. To get off Long Island? I'm just saying, yeah, to get off Long Island. Throggs.
我有个问题要问你，我希望你老实回答我。对，对。好吧。怀石大桥（Whitestone）还是特罗格斯颈大桥（Throg's Neck）？如果你要去韦斯特切斯特。要离开长岛的话？我只是说，对，要离开长岛。特罗格斯。
No, be honest. Throg's neck. Throg's neck. Throg's neck. Oh, shit, you know, landslide. Hey, you know what? We're going to take it out on a high note right there. I don't touch the White Stone.
不，说实话。特罗格斯颈。特罗格斯颈。特罗格斯颈。哦，天哪，你知道的，一边倒。嘿，你知道吗？我们要以一个高潮来结束它。我才不碰怀石大桥。
Kate McKinnon, you're one of the all-time greats. All-time greats. You're a fucking comedy, fucking heavyweight. I swear to God. You know your way around the tri-state area. Oh, my God. You can coax a laugh out of people. She can hammer a nail.
凯特·麦金农，你是史上最伟大的人之一。史上最伟大的人。你是个他妈的喜剧，他妈的重量级人物。我发誓向上帝。你在三州地区游刃有余。哦，天哪。你能逗得大家哈哈大笑。她能锤钉子。
She can pick a carrot. You know how to coax a laugh. You're the best. I can't pick a carrot. Yeah. And I think you could too. By the way, you just buy yourself a little discount next time you go into Lowe's. That's guaranteed.
她能拔胡萝卜。你知道怎么逗人笑。你是最棒的。我不会拔胡萝卜。对。而且我觉得你也会。顺便说一句，下次你去劳氏时，自己拿个小折扣。那是肯定的。
Yeah, they nailed it. Loz. We nailed it. You know what else? Kate, you nailed it today, huh? You did nail it. Oh, thank you, boys. No, you don't like goodbyes.
对，他们做得很棒。劳氏。我们做得很棒。你知道吗？凯特，你今天表现得很棒，哈？你确实表现得很棒。哦，谢谢你们，伙计们。不，你不喜欢告别。
So when you're done, you can just slam that laptop and just blow us a little kiss. And we'll pretend it's not over. And we love you. I love you all. Can't we see you again? Did you get the script yet for Office Christmas Party, too? Just check your inbox. Okay?
所以当你结束时，你只需“啪”地合上那个笔记本电脑，然后给我们一个飞吻。我们就假装还没结束。我们爱你。我也爱你们所有人。我们难道不能再见到你吗？你拿到《办公室圣诞派对》（Office Christmas Party）的剧本了吗？检查一下你的收件箱。好吧？
We'll see on set. I will. I thank you. I'd like to play a different character. No, no, no, yeah, we're all going to rotate. I'd like to play a desk. Oh, so you guys, you two knew each other from that. A little bit.
我们在片场见。我会的。谢谢你们。我想演一个不同的角色。不，不，不，对，我们都会轮流。我想演一张桌子。哦，所以你们，你们俩是从那认识的。有一点。
Oh, we. Yeah, we go so far back. We go back. No, I don't like to talk about my own stuff. It's Black Rabbit, September 18th there on Netflix, or Outlast, if you like reality. Do you guys shoot that in Hiram, Georgia? Is that what you shot off his Christmas party? Well, all I know is a lot of night shoots on a soundstage.
哦，我们。对，我们认识很久了。我们很有渊源。不，我不太喜欢谈论我自己的事。那是9月18日在Netflix上线的《黑兔》（Black Rabbit），或者如果你喜欢真人秀的话，还有《生存极限》。你们是在佐治亚州海勒姆（Hiram）拍那个的吗？那是你们拍《办公室圣诞派对》的地方吗？嗯，我只知道在声音舞台上有很多夜间拍摄。
Yeah. Thanks, everybody. Love you. mean it. Thank you so much. Bye, Kate. We'll see you soon, Kate McKinnon. Everybody read The Purple Pearl. The Purple Pearl. And get ready for the next
对。谢谢大家。爱你们。真心实意。非常感谢。再见，凯特。我们很快会再见到你，凯特·麦金农。大家都去读《紫珍珠》。《紫珍珠》。准备好迎接下一场表演吧
bit of acting from our miss here because she's the tip top. Thank you so much. The great Kate McKinnon, guys. Thank you for doing the show, Kate. All right. Catch you later. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Slam it. Oh, you just leave it. There it is. Yeah.
来自我们的这位女士，因为她是顶尖的。非常感谢。伟大的凯特·麦金农，各位。谢谢你来参加节目，凯特。好的。回见。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。合上。哦，你直接留着。就是这样。对。
Well, now that is it's just a nice person there with incredible levels of talent and creativity all packed into one brain she's made so many people laugh you know on that wiki page they've got all of her impressions listed that she did on Saturday Night Live
好吧，现在这个人真是个很好的人，拥有不可思议的才华和创造力，全都装在一个大脑里，她让那么多人开怀大笑，你知道，在那个维基百科页面上，列出了她在《周六夜现场》模仿过的所有人
it must be like 50 or 60 names there and I didn't even start clicking on them because I would have been late for the record but good Christ do you guys do any impressions truly No Hey Arnett
大概有50或60个名字，我甚至都没有开始点击他们，因为我录制节目要迟到了，但天哪，你们俩会模仿任何人吗，说真的？不，嘿，阿奈特
Stop trying to Google a good buy I'm not I got one Do you really All right keep it Keep it warm Any impressions from either one of you Or actually Sean
别再试图用谷歌搜索“再见”了。我没有，我有一个。真的吗？好吧，保持。保持热度。你们两个有什么模仿秀吗？或者其实，肖恩
We've heard your British cab driver Was it earlier? Yeah that's something like that Okay Wait what's an impression An impression of like a famous person Like what about like Oh remember
我们听过你的英国出租车司机口音。是不是刚才？对，大概类似那样。好吧。等等，什么是模仿？模仿像名人一样？就像比如，哦，记得
Matt did you ever see that show Take your time. Did you ever see that show The Night of? Do you ever see that show on HBO The Night of? Yes, sure. And the older woman who played the prosecutor.
马特，你见过那个节目吗？慢慢来。你见过那个HBO的节目《罪夜之奔》（The Night Of）吗？你见过HBO的那个节目《罪夜之奔》吗？当然见过。那个扮演检察官的老年女性。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. What is her name? She's such an incredible actor. She's so good. I used to imitate her all the time. That's very good. I used to do it. I have it all in my shoulder.
哦，对，对，对。她叫什么名字？她是个不可思议的演员。她太棒了。我以前经常模仿她。非常棒。我以前常这么做。我全身都是戏。
Wait, by the way, you just reminded me of something. I saw over the weekend, Amy Madigan plays a character in a movie called Weapons. Oh, I want to see that movie. This movie is so goddamn good. This guy, Zach Kregor, writer-director, holy shit is he talented. Julia Garner's in it, Josh Brolin's in it.
等等，顺便说一句，你刚才让我想起了一件事。我周末看到艾米·麦迪根（Amy Madigan）在一个叫《武器》（Weapons）的电影里扮演一个角色。哦，我想看那部电影。这部电影太该死的好看了。这家伙，扎克·克雷格（Zach Cregger），编剧兼导演，天哪他太有才了。朱莉娅·加纳（Julia Garner）参演了，乔什·布洛林（Josh Brolin）参演了。
This movie's so freaking good, you guys. I'm serious. No, I heard it's got 100% of Rotten Tomatoes. Amy Madigan plays somebody very disturbing and it's got wigs and teeth and a voice. I'm all in. Oh, my God, is it good. Wigs and a teeth?
这部电影太好看了，伙计们。我是认真的。不，我听说它在烂番茄上获得了100%的好评。艾米·麦迪根扮演了一个非常让人不安的角色，里面有假发、假牙和一种嗓音。我全心支持。天哪，太好看了吧。假发和假牙？
Oh, my God, I love wigs and teeth. It's no, is this thing on, but it'll do until it comes out. Okay? Yeah. And Oscar's keeping things, what is it, keeping it tight, keeping it right with Oscar?
天哪，我喜欢假发和假牙。不是，这个麦克风开着吗，但它能撑到电影上映。好吧？对。还有奥斯卡保持状态，叫什么来着，和奥斯卡保持紧密联系，保持正确？
Let's ask Oscar. Is that what it's called? Let's ask Oscar. No, it's actually called Good Night Oscar, but I wish it was called Good. Bye! Bye! Oscar!
我们问问奥斯卡。是叫这个吗？我们问问奥斯卡。不，其实叫《晚安，奥斯卡》（Good Night Oscar），但我希望它叫“再见！再见！奥斯卡！”
Oh, Lord help. Cue the music. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，天哪。播放音乐。Smartless。Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔贾夫（Rob Armjav）和本尼特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）100%有机且手工打造的。Smartless。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。